vomiting
oh sure we're day
ninety-eight percent yeah we just about
all over time awake almost every day
working on YouTube stuff whether that's
developing or editing or music or
graphics / animation or things like
monitoring the the traffic of what's
going on and stuff like that taken care
of we did a my little pony son recently
and I can't tell you how much time we
spent just removing angry just
controlling kind of things that were
starting these huge flame worth offer
like page after page after page about
whether you know it was cool like my
little pony or late and it was like this
isn't like even relevant anymore to the
video is his name calling now just like
every hour having to come back and like
delete another like 20 posts that were
about things that i'd already deleted
that just still kept going on anyways so
there's some kind of maintenance that
way to
fun I don't think most of them do yeah I
don't think they do people don't realize
what goes into YouTube and it makes me
also look at other peoples YouTube and
go I only see the end product I have no
idea how much the I'm these people I
just been on their drugs to it's
interesting to get a new perspective
watching other people's things going I
can't judge how easy that probably looks
because I have no idea how much time
they spent and then things like traffic
and stuff again on their comments how
many comments they have to remove every
time or not remove respond to things
like that how much they have to send
their stuff up to blogs so it's I think
it takes a lot more time than anyone
who's not tried to start a channel as
their business as their brand it takes a
lot more time than most people probably
assume which is another reason why
trolls exist like if they knew how much
of a person's life was invested in this
they probably wouldn't say you should
probably go out and die they probably
they might say that but they the
internet the internet disguise is how
much work goes into them yeah
you